the meetings so welcome everyone to the
finance and projects many many today we
have both public and public excluded
sessions
um just to note
um
yeah no no offer received no apologies I
don't think there's any apologies
me or you haven't received
any apologies from anyone
no thank you
um
Declarations of interest is there any
decorations of Interest
what no
okay um no public forum we do have two
major laid items one in public which is
the approach to the timing of the museum
that is on the agenda but it's a late
Autumn and then in public excluded we
have um invercar called Central limited
funding status report
which will be covered in public exclude
so can I have a mover in a second
to
receive those late items being the
naming of the museum in the invocation
thanks Tom thanks Leslie all those in
favor against carried
um and the reasons for those just
probably should have stayed this before
we moved it um
those items weren't really in turn for
the publication of their agenda so
um
that's why
right
we're into it okay so
um first item is
the minutes of the meeting for finance
and projects held at Council chamber on
Tuesday the 18th of April so cool
thanks second to Leslie
um all those in favor
aye aye against
any discussion
none
um
the next item is the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of finance and
projects committee held on the 9th of
May Tuesday the 9th of May can I have a
move or understand over there please no
thanks thanks Darren and Leslie
um all those in favor
carried okay any discussion
no
um
next item is the minutes of the
extraordinary meaning for finance and
projects committee
um held Tuesday 22nd of May mover and
seconder thanks
Leslie okay any discussion
they've been none I put that to the
meeting all those in favor
aye aye against carried
right
um automate strategic capital projects
um
could I have a mover and a second to
receive this report please thanks Barry
thanks ringy okay
Lee welcome
to chat
ready
so I'll take the reporters red but as I
typically do I'll just run through a bit
of a summary on of each of the projects
on the dashboard
um city street stage one obviously this
Project's now incomplete and we're now
going through this defects period and
we're just awaiting a final report from
the project team to close out all the um
accounts and bits and pieces with that
it's estimated they come incredibly
close to our budget as you'll see on the
dashboard and like I said just as we're
working out a few uh the last accounts
and by the time we come to the next the
next committee that will be closed
stair Street Stock Bank as with city
streets it's in that defects phase we're
just closing out that that one actually
is a little bit further along in its
close that period and again we're
showing just a a small
um under budget there of a couple
hundred thousand
which is good there's a few little tidy
up and teething things that the team are
working on there and that's around
um landscaping and people using that
boom near the airport which the team are
working on
um around parking and stuff on the berm
there's on Airport Ave so that's a
little um a little bit of something that
we're working on through there
the banks on water main
so stage one is now practically complete
for a more projects uh standpoint so
that is technically complete now we're
in a defects period but ranksoma stage
once that pipe is all now been tested
those are used North Road will notice
there's still a little bit of work just
near Prime range meets there as we're
closing up the testing chamber and doing
that that'll be done over the next few
days hopefully
and one good thing is we've now moved a
contractor into the letter of award for
stage two and three
so in the next we were we'll be able to
put out a bit more Communications about
that we've managed to secure a
contractor from South Canterbury to come
down to invercargill and help us deliver
the next few stages of uh branksome
it's been an incredibly difficult
project for us to Tender in the market
we've put it out a number of times and
had one response which has been
unfortunately really quite a bit over
our budget so we had a really the team's
really had a think out the box
on this one and we've had a canvas a lot
of councils and other organizations like
us that have done projects like this and
try to find someone that's got a lot of
experience and then finding someone with
that's got a lot of experience and
they're able to price it a lot more
competitively and a lot closer to our
budget
it's a little bit disappointing me I've
been able to use local resources for it
but we've got a project partner now
that's got lots and lots of experience
and a lot more aligned with our budget
so that'll happen
very quickly over the next couple of
months you'll start to see
these contracted vehicles in town
rugby park so obviously we've had a
couple of meetings with the committee on
that and the next stage of park has been
approved so we're into so that
stakeholder meetings and we've had a
couple of um meetings on site with
designers and Consultants looking at the
strengthening works and looking at other
bits and pieces that need to be done
through the park so that's now wheels
are rolling on that one so it's great to
get that one off the ground
the cab
continues to be a bit of a challenge
we had planned to bring a report to you
guys at this meeting and I apologize for
that we're still
uh trying to work out that one that's
quite a complicated puzzle and so we've
now gone through the whole
um building assessment
phase of that so now we understand
really from the building maintenance
point of view where we are and what we
didn't want to do is just bring that
report to you without the broader
picture
um so we will we will bring that to the
next financing projects meeting
the museum
all three projects so the museum to
attire and storage are all well and
truly in flight
the storage project uh we're now but the
roof is now on the building and we're
now cladding the walls so we'll soon
have a weather type building which is
great it's on track on budget on program
so hats off to everybody involved in
that including our contractors
the museum
we obviously are in the concept phase of
that design and that's really exciting
times and we're starting to shape up now
with a plan to come to Council on the
17th of July and show Council for the
first time what the guys have been
working on and the early concepts of the
museum we're also in the latter stages
of the experience uh Supply piece where
we have shortlisted a candidate and they
are coming to invercargill to interview
with us in the next couple of weeks
again because we're in a tender
situation I can't talk too much about
that but yet again another Stellar
um candidate
amazing repertoire of work and I can't
wait to bring you more news on that
and the Tuatara today we had our second
uh concept uh design meeting with a lot
of different stakeholders up in
Wellington
um with experts there and here in
invercargill with our Ewan
um other stakeholders again you know
it's starting to shape up looking really
really cool um it's like an early
concept stage so again I don't really
want to talk too much more about that
until we bring it out to to you a bit
more formally but another you know
another cool piece of work really
shaping up really well so the whole
program 1225 is on track on budget and
really really going well so I can't uh I
can't say anything more highly to the
team they really cranking that one along
really well
Bluff boat ramp so we've gone through a
lot of engineering we've put our first
test Pile in the seabed that's tested it
well we now have a firm understanding of
what the piling method is we've engaged
through our Engineers a contractor and
we're just waiting for a delivery date
for them to deliver the three more piles
that we need to install and over the
next couple of months we'll be going out
to the market with our design for our
pontoons to get that price within the
market
so I'd expect in the next
probably six months or so we'll have
those pontoons actually in the water in
stage one of uh Bluff boat ramp will be
complete our focus is now stage two
which is what we call the dry side
facility so looking at toilets parking
that whole Arrangement down there so
that's where the project team is
starting to turn their focus to now as
we feel that we've got stage one
um well and truly wrapped up our consent
is in with the Romans environment
Southland for the West Jetty as well and
that's under review so again that one
has taken a little while to get off the
ground but now we're pretty happy we're
up on the plane away which we're tipping
along quite nicely on on that project
and last but not least on the list is a
house innovation
a contractor has been awarded abl
and they're soon to break ground in the
next couple of weeks and uh the delivery
of those houses will be well and truly
underway
so hopefully
um there's a lot of green on the on the
dashboard at the moment there's a lot of
physical activity happening whether it's
design or physical construction and our
Capital program is yeah moving moving
well and moving well at PACE
yeah thanks Lee Tom
Lee when you talked about the cab
project you said that the report which I
think was due this month was delayed
because
we had been asking for a report I think
about what was required in a maintenance
upgrade and you said you wanted to give
the broader context
um I know we're going to see that maybe
next month because it gives a flavor for
this a broader context mean um
it's not a great read
from a building maintenance point of
view it's not a great read and I think
if you read that in without the context
of what the project behind that would be
which is what a refurb would look like
um setting it out uh for the for us for
the future you would take a fairly dim
view of this building
so in isolation the maintenance pace is
a challenge in itself you know many
millions of dollars and it's you know
there's a lot of red on it rather than
green and Amber so it's um yeah it
paints a very um
it's a very dim picture and I think if
we brought that to council right now
um it wouldn't it wouldn't be the best
report to be honest with you
thank you thanks ringy just following on
from Tom on that subject now I mean
we're at a stage where I I can see this
dragging on forever and we're going to
have our staff which are a sizable
number working in conditions where the
windows Rattle and blow and the heating
systems goes when it wants to and look
it's frustrating in the sense that
we've done this floor and it's very
functional we've done the ground floor
the reception area is very functional
the the location of this building is
premium it's north facing you wouldn't
want to shift and do a new build from
what I hear the structurally it's
earthquake sound
um
and and when you look at the old Menzies
building over there it's getting done up
into a four-star hotel
and money's getting invested that to
reclaad to re-window
and and obviously have plush rooms now
I'm just struggling to understand why we
can't use that same Innovation to do
this building up I really can't and even
if it has to be known plural by floor
when budget comes free I
I don't know
it's just one I can't get my head around
that we seem to be the wheels just keep
spinning and we get more reports
and it's too daunting and we'll I mean I
could be here in two years and get the
same report
I think the first point I'll make is
that the initial budget didn't fit our
aspirations
so that's the first point I'd like to
make second Point we've been asked to
look at it in somewhat a different way
of Maintenance focused and we have that
information now and that's like I say in
isolation
is in the right report to bring to
council to be fair
and you know you could do it floor by
floor but the moment the budget doesn't
fit the aspiration there's bigger
problems to unpack has been a bit
complicated
but we want to bring the best
information forward for Council to make
the best decision rather than just going
at it
yeah welcome here
thank you um I thought it was just worth
me adding some context to this one
because as much as Lee apologized for
that not one not being here
um it was probably more me asking for
some further information that that's um
prevented that report being here today
um one of the things we were really
conscious of is as Lee said we've got a
report sitting there with a an awful lot
of red around the condition of the
building that's really telling us that
the building is getting very much to um
towards the the end of usable life
before we have to start spending some
really significant money on it
um we would spend a significant portion
of that existing allocation of money
just to tick off some of those really
red items
um and my concern was around coming back
to council saying this is how we're
going to allocate that that money that
you've got set aside this is the couple
of items it's going to tick off and then
not have a picture for what then we have
to do in another three years time and
then another three years time after that
another three years time after that
wanted to make sure that Council very
much had the picture of
um not only that first investment of
money that we'd have to make but then
that next investment and next investment
and next investment
um so that you're able to make a fully
informed decision
um to what um councilor pottinger was
talking about is is that the right
approach redoing this building a bit at
a time
um or whether or not we should be be
doing something different so to that
point about about trying to give elected
members all of the information that you
need to make as an informed decision as
possible rather than than part of the
information and then you guys having to
try to decide what you're going to do
with only part of that picture okay
thank you any other questions
Barry yes as far as far as the boat ramp
goes down in Bluff there's quite a few
Moorings around the front of it
um
because of the drive in there there's
quite a few Moorings in front have they
been notified that they'll have to
remove those or
not know is the answer for that as
something that we have done
something we can definitely look into
well it's under the jurisdiction of the
um
Southport own though it controls that
Waterway so that would be something that
they because I know I was I've hopped
onto the ropes before yeah no it's
coming
did you hear
yeah just a brief reflection
um
I'm pleased that we'll get a report that
allows to decide on the future where
Council says in relation to this
building
um at the beginning of this term we were
very clear with staff that we were not
committing 28 million dollars to the
upgrading of disability
and that's there's some records of the
amount it seems that we've scaled back
to 15 or 16 which is where it was about
two years prior to becoming 28
um but it'll be helpful to get the
information that there because um while
rangi said he's quite right that we
should be uh not doing this bit by
bitter we could be doing it bit by bit
we also need to consider whether our
medium-term future is here or whether
it's somewhere else
um so I've got quite an open mind on
that
yeah and it was sort of a question I was
gonna
ask
um so
well my mom we need to do two things we
need to look at what is the how much do
we need to invest to make this building
useful for the next 50 years
or what are what is the alternative why
do we move somewhere else and partner
with someone else to build a completely
new building and the Dynamics of the CBD
have changed in the last two or three
months you we all know why that is so
um I think that's what we need to be
able to see is you know what's what's
the cost of making this building you
know usable for the next 50 years in a
functional way for stuff and is there
opportunity to partner with someone else
in here or do we is it better for us to
look at somewhere else in the city with
someone else if that makes sense so when
would we receive well we would we be in
a position to receive something like
that
well chair the report is there
um I think
to expand a wee bit more on what I was
talking about earlier when we just
looked at the maintenance on its own
it's actually come back at such a number
that has caused us to go holy moly yeah
so uh I think that's that's part one
part two what we've been what we've
decided to do
for the best for the better uh
information for Council is revisit the
path that what we've done in the past
break it down into stages and bring a
report that looks at the future looks at
the maintenance because the money alone
just for maintenance yeah is is
exasperating most of our budget and
that's just dealing with maintenance
yeah so to bring that to the table would
just be the wrong thing to do yeah so
what we're trying to what we're doing
because the reports are all there we're
now looking to rehash and bring together
a better report that looks at
maintenance but also looks at the past
project that we looked at
um last year and a year and a half ago
now at this point so it's a bit more of
a combined report so we're just we're
just bringing all the information
together but but does it look at
potential partnering with someone else
no because that's not in scope at the
moment but it may Force Council to give
us a bit more Direction and tell us what
else they want us to look at to be fair
yeah okay I've got Ella and ninobi is
your question related to this or another
yeah okay so can all go to knobby it is
right okay
sometimes they aren't
not yours necessarily
in the scope of what you're looking at
would you perhaps
perhaps including that into a new Civic
buildings is that sort of kind of what
you might come back before us no no if I
think what we'd like to come back to you
with is
this building yeah
full review of this building so you can
then decide right this isn't the home
for us long term
these are Big Numbers we don't just want
to pass it up or do the maintenance
piece and you and I think councilors
what may come back to us and ask staff
to look at further options there's a
supplementary to that yeah quite a good
idea for us to know exactly
yeah
what you're going to do here because if
you don't know what the elephant's going
to cost it's really hard to make a
decision
yeah and and to that end I think you
know if we went to a party and said look
do us a design and build for this bigger
space
in a sort in the CBD is a concept Design
Within we get an alternative realm we
invest in here or we go with a different
projects
yeah yeah
yeah I love to increase the scope to
look at some master planning and look at
some alternative options yeah yeah I
don't we don't want to boil the ocean
but I do think we need the alternative
just informs the decision better knobby
yeah mine was on the same same issue
again of not just considering what we've
got here and how much it will cost going
forward
um I think when we discussed this six
months ago one of the things that we
were going to wait for was to wait to
see what came out of the future for
Local Government Review which is you'll
be aware is embargo until tomorrow but
I'm not breaking any confidentiality
that there is some discussion around the
malformation of councils without being
too specific and so um
you know given that we know that our
biggest name of the South District
Council was also struggling for space it
would be remiss of us not to consider a
combined space even if we're not
Amalgamated given that we own a big
chunk of land that on the current Ico
block which we which we have some
ownership of I mean and so it would be
helpful to have the comparison even
though small part figures I do have some
tentative figures for an eight-story
building on that site and what that
would cost dollars wise costed out by uh
um a quantity surveying firm away from
invercargill so I've got a ball pack on
that side but what I'd like to know from
this side is what we're going to take to
upgrade this building how long will we
need to stay here and if we don't do it
all at once and but more importantly
what's the value of this building if we
on sell it
yeah yeah they just because that's part
of the equation as well yeah yeah Tom
my question I guess goes in the same
direction and it was and and they're
probably premature because I think we're
at least seeing that you know you it
kind of broke to the the the fact that
we're going to get reported on this
building specifically rather than the
future but inevitably it means that we
are thinking about the future noon and
and my question was I I think it would
be helpful Lee when you bring that
people that's all red
would be an understanding of
um if we knew that we were going to
build another building let's just
suppose if there was an option of
building and moving
um how many years would it be before I
mean could we spend I know it doesn't
mean nothing but it could be spend
nothing in this building for five years
yeah if we knew the end it I'm not
really asking a question at the moment
I'm more just kind of you know giving a
better lead into what you might hear
when you you bring it you know could you
spend almost nothing in this for five
years in the basis that you could then
save that and towards building a new
building yeah I think that's where um
this report's come back the maintenance
pro has come back you know quite slow
there's a lot of red I don't think we
have an option of doing nothing for a
long period of time and that's
complicated the conversation yeah yeah
it's a useful life isn't it so you can
merge the two if you decide to move it
might be spend some money here to get
three years life out of this in a
reasonable way and then move in that
time you're also going down the second
path of having a new
bedroom if you know you're going to move
next week so that's uh
not when you're using other people's
money
okay um any other questions relating to
the report
just in relation to project 1225 and Lee
and I have discussed this but I just
want some clarity around it
um it was my understanding that the
design brief for the new Museum would
include physically include some Tuatara
being present and I just want us to be
clear that if that is the case word is
no longer the case
for the brief is the briefing we have
physical Tuatara in the brief four
Museum
as it stands at the moment again I don't
want to predispose no design and we want
to bring the experienced team on board
as well so I think the best best thing
to do is to let those designers do their
magic and let us debate that at the
right time yeah and what I asset chair
is is that we've had some publicity
obviously on on that project which is
really exciting it's good but some of
the feedback that we've had going back
out to people that say well now that
you're building a new tuatarium in the
center of the park which is also great
does that mean you're not going to have
a link in the museum and the reply from
the organization has been we haven't
made the decision on there so that
throws some confusion on with the
community yeah we're quite Keen to have
the Tuatara even just a small number
yeah so if I could sort of lean into
that a little bit with Mother head-on I
think at some point we need to
understand the fullness of that decision
and and we'll get something at some
point I can't think when it's on the
Skype if it is on the scope but we will
need to bring something to council
around the the wholeness of that
discussion and decision
about the Twitter and I think just you
know just to clear up some of the
confusion that the pituitary facility in
the park is forward is forward-looking
we understand through experts in
Wellington who have already done this
that and are working on the husbandry
manual which is you know the guidebook
and how you how best to look after
um these these animals is that
this is where the guidance is going
so the Tuatara enclosure in the
um in the Queen's Park is is preparing
us for changes we know is going to
happen in the guidance of looking after
um these animals so we're just looking
forward
to make sure that we're well placed to
look after those the best those animals
the best way possibly can doesn't rule
out
uh Museum now yeah and and so is it
reasonable to maybe think that yeah the
Tuatara are absolutely a fundamental
part of the Queen's Park experience but
whether they're specifically related and
the museum is to be determined yeah sure
yeah okay
right
right we've had a mover and secondary
any further questions before we
vote on receiving the report strategic
capital projects and
the dashboard
now just can I say prior yeah thanks
very much the project team Lee I know
you're doing a fantastic job and to have
us where we are in a number of projects
has ruining credit to your team so thank
you thank you chair
right all those in favor of accepting
the two
against
not carried
next
street
City streetscapes
so can I have a move in a second to
receive
this report thanks not uh ring and
thanks Tom
okay Russell welcome
yeah
and reflecting while I was sitting down
there I perhaps thought that perhaps my
report would have been perhaps better to
have been titled uh City Street's next
stages perhaps rather than stage two
um I guess we've seen quite a bit of uh
continue with his change in the city
center over the last little while and
really there's been lots of discussion
about what's next and this report looks
to try to I guess prioritize that and
actually focus on what the next stages
that are necessary
um attention necessary for a study to
progress and also partner with some of
that outside investment going forward
um I think there are lots of
opportunities but really I've tried to
write the report in a way that actually
brings together the information we have
today and we've discussed a number of
strategic workshops
um I do apologize the recommendation
number five up there really doesn't
align correctly with the financial
implications and I'm suggesting that
that perhaps isn't considered and
deleted and as we can have a discussion
on that because that really
um probably needs to be
um
undertaking and
recommendation sex where we'd actually
establish a budget with some costs
associated with what the planning would
be so I think that's probably a little
bit premature and my apologies that was
in a draft that one section got changed
and then it deleted so
suggestions happy to take questions
thanks Russell um so I've got knobby
nimring yep thank you um just to reflect
that when I read this paper I got really
confused Russell so just help me clarify
some things
um I understood it in earlier workshops
that we've had that we collectively
agreed well by majority agreed that we
wouldn't proceed with stages two and
three which is down Kelvin Street and
this way up S Street that was canceled
and we had John Green here at the time
um and that we would focus on what will
replace and what goes to s Street West
and I'm not sure when I see a report
this report that says that the budget
for State Street 2 which is the Kelvin
Precinct
which is running between Don and esk on
Kelvin at 13.6 million dollars is for 25
20 24 25 onwards that wasn't my recall
we politely paused it but there was no
intention to to jump into that and so
I'd seek some clarification on that but
I do have some other questions as well
so thanks chair
the intention of the report has been to
try to clarify exactly
um I mean I'll be talking about so stage
two is really I've described it as the
Calvin Street precinct whatever that
might mean it when it's more fully
scoped and I guess stage three is what I
call history West which is the other
Precinct and and the absence of guests
having a number of names
I've tried to say there's two distinct
parts and they and they are and can run
independently at whatever timing Council
so chooses
um
from the roadmap my understanding was
that the Calvin Street Works was
proposed at a later time and was paused
but the budget was actually set at that
13.6 which was the amount that we
consulted the public on
got it ring in there now again uh Ellen
thanks chair
look um being on the committee with John
Green
it was all it was always our
understanding that stage two was Kelvin
Street
and S Street East
as stage two and stage three was always
gonna be
that way walk into place and hit uh s
Street West now I I actually like the
report
um especially when it actually
prompts us to make a decision
if you go to recommendation eight uh
then choosing the the developer takes
the lead and brings back ideas to
council for us to either like dislike
alter
I think that's that's a very good work
Russell that that option is there and
I'd be quite happy to actually oh before
I move that we go for eight
see I'd like to say that uh now that H J
Smith has now has done its announcement
and we still don't have
any firm idea of what south of the
Kelvin hotel is going to be
um Kelvin Street really
and around this area here and if people
now seem to not like this place anymore
um then then
really that should just be put in the
put on hold and we just move ahead if
that budget is that budget still usable
for stage three is the one approved for
stage two is it or is it being dipped
into a wee bit
um
my understanding is that that's a
forward but it's a forward
the budget so we need to be Revisited
yeah okay so I'd like to actually move
that recommendation eight is that we go
for I think it's recommendation seven
isn't it you're talking about was it
seven now yeah it's up on the screen
here oh sorry I'm looking at the book
yeah sorry yeah seven see
yeah yeah
yeah thank you Ellen I'm sorry Mr chair
um Ellen before you speak I would ask um
councilor Ludlow to share a microphone
with you we're having difficulty picking
you up
I didn't realize
got two microphones in front of him so
if your brain shuffles down ones you
know you're a greedy yes
so it wasn't stereo some people like to
hear this sounded their own voices
some of us do it professionally sorry to
interrupt if you want to accelerate
yourself to our level you're welcome I
don't want to
um I'll just do like to say that I was
actually just
not as not going to say it as well as
what ring you did but I was just going
to pretty much say the same thing
actually very good report and I also
like well I was going to be calling it
HC as well but so you see now it's 7c
and I just recollect
um a developer in that area offering to
assist a Zeta also in further option
than you're thinking they did
financially assist I believe was the
offer that was made at the time and I
thought well you know there's a option
for that surely we should
Mr chair I think that's that's obviously
there's a huge interest from the
developer and we should have that
conversation yeah so so that would be
part that that was the case when Jeff
came to present yeah
um and so that would be part I'd see
that when we get the report back around
if we go with this recommendation to
prioritize stage three which is the
walk in a place piece that then Russell
would engage with the developer and and
part of that would be their contribution
to
excellent yeah yeah
I mean I definitely support 7c my
question
was about the timing given that the new
hotel is likely to be up and running at
some point next year as I understand it
there's no team you lose basically and
and you know and and that suggests to me
a timeline and making this happen which
is faster than it probably we're done in
Adelie
um so Russell do you have in your mind
though again a project plan that will
deliver us to do other stuff in good
time
Mr T one of the things that we learned
from stage one was that we jumped on a
bullet train
toured in escondon Street and I guess
using the time we have between now and
mid to late next year where I understand
that hotel is due to open
um is actually the most vital thing and
the potential I guess for for those
options were that
um some of those options have a an
ability to I guess progress much faster
have perhaps different rules for
procurement but we need to make sure
that we do protect um
appropriate business practice and good
consultation practice through that
because I guess all of those still
things need to come back to council
because the area that we're talking
about developing is public space
so so just to get some clarity if we go
with what you've recommended here and it
is C
you would you would bring a paper back
to us
that would scope out that project in
more detail including develop
contributions in a time frame
and then it would get handed through to
the Project's team to manage that
project
that's correct chair that um we do need
to develop that whole picture so that we
actually know what what we're buying a
buying into and why that what that's
delivering and at what time because I
guess those are the things that are uh
have got lots of elements in people's
minds and expectations and it may well
be that our expectations to join within
the principles of the city center master
plan don't necessarily may not
necessarily always align with the
developers but it's about trying to get
those in a common place and a common
time
McGee's the strongest benefit in those
is that you actually are linking to
someone who has that I guess that
invested interest of actually meeting
time just like we had some of the issues
we faced in East Street and down street
where we had big developments right on
our doorstep and he he do two things in
the same space is always a challenge
yeah and without you having explored it
in too much detail you you feel it's
deliverable I think it's October next
year that they're sort of looking for an
opening it's deliverable
if I go with it haven't thought there
will be elements that will be
deliverable um I guess some of the
consultation and and how you might make
conversations with the community and
then decide on what the outcomes would
be through what in a place may take more
out more time but I think you've been a
much there's a potential of being in a
good place by then okay so here's Leslie
then knobby then Tom
thanks Mr chair
um I was just going to reflect if we're
tending towards 7c
whether it's a better signal to slightly
alter that inhibitors Joint Council
developer lead
at the moment the implication of what's
the year
is almost that will accept whatever the
developer wants and it's no comment on
the particular this particular developer
but it is thinking about the future
signal to developers it might just be a
good idea to have the joint Concept in
there from that point
um and I'm happy to move two to six
which I don't think has yet been moved
no we haven't had a movie we'll just
take a couple more comments and then
we'll get them over so we hit knobby
then
Evelyn then Tom
um so I was a little bit confused I need
to go back a step three
um and D there we're floating the option
of
um
uh design preliminary designs for stages
two and three so it's Kelvin and S
Street East
um I'm quite clear that at the beginning
of this term we we put both those on
pause
and if we're now bringing forward s
Street West as a party which it clearly
it needs to be with the new hotel then
the obvious way to fund it is not to
come back with a new budget but it's a
funded out of the money that we've
already paused so we've paused by my
estimation about 21 million dollars
worth under the under that 21 20 uh
sorry under
um under design stages two and three so
it's Kelvin and
uh history East we're about 21 million
will take a bit of change and and the
original budgets which is what we paused
if we leave it paused and make it a
longer term thing and a long-term plan
to consider that funds what we need to
do in
um in air Street West which is down by
the new hotel including walking the
place and it doesn't Force us to put up
an additional budget it leads us to come
back to the original if we think it's
needed further down the track I'm yet to
be convinced that doing s Street East
which is where we currently sit is an
ideal location to develop an inner city
block
that encourages foot traffic when it
hits within it to large car Parks it
just doesn't make any sense to me and
now a great big store right next to us
that is closed
uh or about to close yeah
yeah I think and I may have it wrong but
I think that was the nature of the paper
wasn't it that we're going to put s
Street West as the priority and we're
going to transfer the budget which I
think is 13 million residual would be
prioritized District risk in doing that
and by doing that we're pausing Kelvin
Street in East Street East that's that's
the context of the paper in in summary
isn't it so just to the point of that
year if you look at number four I love
you it says confirm stage two which is
the Kelton Street Press Precinct it's
planned for 24.25 so that's next year
um yeah 25 26 years so that's over a two
fiscal year period and budget is
required for the long-term plan design
works so so we know that we don't need
that we just park it up and leave it for
a while Mr chair it might be that four
could be reworded to actually
take out the reference the sage too but
bring in the reference to 13.6 million
being reallocated yep absolutely that
would capture the concept that's on page
30. yeah because page 30 actually refers
to city street under financial
application City street stage two has
paused and the 13.6 million is allocated
from 2024 to 25 onwards so four is
reworded to reflect that oh yeah I think
it's capturing what we're talking about
so Mr chair one of the things with um
both stages that I've referred to as two
and three we haven't necessarily got to
a point in time where we can allocate a
budget for each of those areas I think
that's the that's a key thing because
the 13.6 might be enough to Shear across
both and therefore you could time it but
I think part of that first piece has to
recognize that the piece of work that
was planned for the Calvin Street
precinct can be
I guess paused and
but
the allocation that was that was
consulted with the with the public
will need to be
reconsulted as we understand better what
stage three will be required for for
East Street West yeah
yeah so so in essence we're we're just
holding the money looking to transfer it
across and that would be part of
consultation
and we're pausing the the Kelvin Street
near Street thing so I think
you know we can probably
in terms of the
um
motions
we just a mean three
and include the 30 Millions relocated
there and we scrap four
so we agree that with e strip whisk is
the priority and needs to be Advanced
and align with adjacent timelines and
prioritize the 13 million that's
allocated within the long-term plan
and then Force
well I think I think the long-term plan
has more than that for my recollection
I think we did Dawn and S together and
then the next job was to do Kelvin and S
Street yes and for my recollection the
costing was somewhere around the 19 20
21 Mark for those two pieces of work so
if we're pausing and we have a
significant chunk of work I think the
other thing would be helpful is if we
want to talk about s Street West we
should just call it walking a place
because it's getting really confusing
about people about that's yeah different
projects within history we've now got
three of them yeah so so let's take that
recommendation around walk the place and
maybe we just leave that budget number
out of it knowing that we're gonna have
to come back to reallocate it and
consult one yeah I think item um
recommendation five identifies that we
need to return with a budget for stage
three
and
it suggests that the timing timings for
works for stage two can be reallocated
yeah
I was going to suggest the change to
recommendation for there I think the
easiest way to resolve it is to put the
words at the end of that as is paused
because it means it's not deleted it's
not revoked you can come back to it but
it's on hold it's a clear signal that
it's on hold which then allows what Mr
Pearson has just suggested as the
reallocation of the budget yeah yeah but
you can still come back to it in some
time because it has been consulted on as
part of the long-term plan work okay so
do we need to move it or mean Network
Windows do it under no I think uh we're
probably getting to the stage of needing
to do each of those resolutions
um
individually yeah just to ensure that
everybody is on board with each of them
and we've still got
five speakers to go yeah yeah so we'll
get through the speakers
so we've got Evelyn Tom Leslie ring and
Enderman
um Russell and part has really covered
over what I was going to say I think
welcome to place alteration is a
significant change to what we have
consulted the public on and I would be
really uncomfortable it's not just a
matter of transferring money from one
place to the other this is actually got
more implications than that and I don't
think that we can just sort of say well
we don't need to consult them because
we've got the money I think it's the
changes that it's going to make to the
Dynamics of that area of the town really
need to be considered and people need to
have a chance to exercise their their
voices about so
um I'm not saying that Russell or nobody
has thought about it but Russell did
refer to it while I was waiting so
democracy and that perspective we have
consulted on this area we have not
consulted on that yeah and no I think
Darwin offered suggests that we don't
consult
I just wanted to make sure
accepting Evelyn's point of the
Democracy I mean it's inconceivable that
we could arrive at a point where the new
distinction Hotel was opening and that's
a building site
yeah because you can have people come to
a distinction haven't they walk across a
building site to get up to town so it's
going to be done so I I think we we we
have to set that stake in the ground
that the work will be complete or at
least you know most of the work put past
and so forth would be complete by
whatever is October next year
um and then what back through that and
say well in what order to me to do
things because again I'm just repeating
myself but you simply can't have people
coming to the hotel and it's a building
site
um but I mean obviously except what
Evelyn has just said yeah I'm sorry the
other thing I was going to say is I
think we should change C to
um as Leslie suggested to say
um a developer Council leader Council
last develop because again it's
inconceivable you just like develop into
it once
Mr chair think under the significance
policy we indicate that the change that
we're proposing through this report
actually requires us to actually go to
consultation
is the significance policy will be
connected so yeah
which would confirm Evelyn's position
okay Leslie
thanks Mr chair I was I was just going
to comment further about
um
rewording four slightly and I don't
think we're quite the year yet Michael
because just adding is paused
leaves are perhaps a little bit clumsy
starting at stage two I'm wondering if
if it would be really clearer as to what
we're intending to say confirms that
stage two Calvin precinct which was
planned for 20 24 25.
and then is paused yeah I think it
probably conveys yeah agree yeah thank
you cheers bring it look
I mean if you read the report this is
quite clearly and three which describes
is the backstory for developer lead
you do not need
select Council slash developer you don't
the the fine print says it all that
talks about consultation it talks about
some limiting plans for Council for
approval
uh clear guns would be needed on Council
expectations
that
Michael you might need to correct me
here but I believe that statement in the
report
comes with if we
before you choose that that is all part
of it
um so I don't think we need to add any
words we're just getting too wordy and I
think we stick the way Russell wrote it
that's absolutely because
it's all in the fine print and that's
what it says why do you have to keep
writing in extra stuff yeah I I think
probably what this does
um it reflects the intent with which the
council nurse want to go for on it we
want it to be a joint lead project and I
I think Leslie raises a good point
around precedent if we just have
something that says there a developer
lead and then we get someone else come
along and all of a sudden they start
hauling us together how come you let
them lead the project and you're not
letting us so I think for consistency
and for intent in terms of what this
Council wants to do we want this to be a
jointed and when Jeff came here and sat
here and indicated very strongly that he
wants to work alongside with us and so
this is just reflecting that by putting
that in there so I think that's
reasonable it already says that in that
state yeah so just changing the wording
just reflects it in the motion I think
it changes the whole idea I really do
it's all right I I don't feel that way
Nobby
oh sorry dear dear
it's all right to mix the tour
not as sorry as the mirrors but
um I just wonder whether or not the
significance policy which obviously
would be triggered is covered up with
the fact that we've actually already
done a reasonable degree of consultation
about the future of walking a place in
the past that's as an aside
um my question was really for Russell on
the scoping report that comes back is
that likely to include along with esque
Street West and and walk the place the D
Street connection between esk and Don
that was being talked about
she I don't initially it wasn't intended
to but I think that to address some of
the I guess the
um
renewal improvements it might be
necessary in those sections as in
footpath renewals rather than the
structural change to the environment
would be part of a renewals program
rather than necessarily and
acknowledging that that's a section of
footpath that needs some love sometime
in the near field I think that's that's
all John referred to as just that
um light level linking between the two
streets thank you okay
okay any other questions
oh no I just uh was agreeing with with
ringy to a point I think it was not
necessary to the council develop there
because it's already explained over but
I also think that we need to be mindful
of that particular developer who did
offer US money
has walked away from us before
because of um
the feelings they had a bad a bad
working relationship
so I think you know it wouldn't be a
silly idea to send the signal that um
you're probably quite happy to lead him
he's obviously playing the obviously
going to do with Council because you
can't just go developing and I don't
think I said it's a precedent because
every every every action has taken on
this mirror or every
every possible future development has
taken on this mirror at the time
yeah yeah we for me I'll stay away from
this Council develop a lead issue but
just to reflect that um where we have
had
um the group that rang you as involved
with John Green and we've had ICL
involved things have been delivered on
time and pretty well on budget and don't
take this wrong way Russell but where
we've had stuff that we've LED we
haven't been on time and we haven't been
on budget and I think it's important to
do these joint ventures with people
um he's got an incentive to make sure
that what in place is okay for his hotel
we have that as well but we have the
other needed with potential bus access
through that walk in the place there's
going to be controversial for some
people in the public we need to get out
and consult on that very early on and
make sure that we can deliver on time
because as Russell said the time frames
are eye-wateringly tight on this but we
can't afford to have a new Hotel open
while we still go to construction site
sitting out there Jeff has made an offer
he said he'll be prepared to put money
into the development of workman place
and by that he didn't mean the bus lane
going through he was talking more about
the recreational stuff that would sit
there and those intensive plans that he
gave us which is a bit more on the
Tuatara
Lodge side of Wagner place which I
thought was really positive
okay good discussion right so we have
it doesn't move again no it doesn't
um
a number of motions there
um so can we have a mover and a second
for those motions with
C being the preferred option in seven
that we're moving I'll I'll move them
one at a time
okay tomorrow suggested so do you wanna
you wanna move the first one second to
my I was going to move them and then
suggest they'd be taken
actually
you can have a mover and a sector second
domestic chair and then each resolution
is put one at a time to vote in fact
okay right so move her in a second to
further overall so Leslie in Tom thank
you okay now we'll go through each of
them so the first one about if you want
to do that again so
um just yeah all those in favor of
against
okay two all those in favor are against
carried all those in favor of three
thank you against
all those in favor of four
against carrot uh all those in favor of
five
all those in favor of six
against carried and all those in favor
of 7c
aye aye against
good work Russ so get on with it
all right
um Financial update
actually all gonna stay here into this
I'm gonna stay here for this one and do
it
okay so can I have a move in a second to
receive this report please thanks Barry
thanks Leslie right so this um good
afternoon councils this is the uh
regular reporting that we would give on
the financials uh for this
I've covered off both the true we
covered off both the treasury position
as it the 31st of May
um as well as the depth position at the
end of April
and it gives the sensitive expenditure
reporting
and some expense variance analysis
there's a couple of points that I do
want to note in relation to treasury we
are currently still got that small
treasury breach which we've been
monitoring for a number of months and
there is now an action in place to to
take out some forward starting swaps as
the market is starting to turn there
other than a knit deep position that's
sitting at 58 million
in
terms of sensitive expenditure that
listing for
the mere councilors and chief executive
is outlined there
and the other one that I wanted to just
note
to counselors when I get to it
in relation to where rate set it is
coming down significantly
um now that we've started to see because
of the regular reporting that we've been
doing to you we can see that it does
fluctuate in a pattern and through the
next financial year you'll start to see
that as a graph
um because there is a trend starting to
appear that we can see
and the other point which uh colleagues
over at Southern District raised a
couple of weeks ago with the timing of
the uh
committees are slightly out we are also
seeing a significant increase in the
saunas and our direct debits for rates
and that's to do with bank processing
changes so now that they've gone to the
seven day processing
a number of air
ratepayers do not have enough money in
their bank accounts when the direct
debit is processed by the bank
we actually saw it ahead of many of the
councils around the country
in relation to One Bank being Westpac
but the other thing that you do need to
be aware and with has been a little bit
of noise from customers about it at
present at bank cannot provide us with
the transactions from Saturday and
Sunday until Tuesday
which means if a customer was to ring up
knowing that they have paid on Saturday
or Sunday
we cannot get it against their accounts
till Tuesday at the earliest that is an
issue with their bank and they are busy
trying to work out how they can change
their reporting so we can suck that feed
into our system
so just a question on that through you
chair Patricia does
does that mean there is the potential
for
the debt to still be showing us
outstanding for that Monday even though
it's not yeah it is frustrating so it
has happened where a number of customers
and that's why we're going
and then we've been working with our
bank to try and with it's the bnz to try
and get it so that we can get the
transactions on a more timely basis
okay any questions with regard to the
report
um Tom and then
it's just me first um on the
cover breach
that we have a certain internal policy
breach a result it's an internal policy
it's an internal policy but it doesn't
breach of any lending requirements it's
just our internal policy that we need to
have so much fixed debt edited fixed
interest at a certain important time and
we've got
a marine thinking then that the point
that you're making is that because of
that breach
if we go to borrow more money then that
would be taken into account and we might
end up paying higher interest rate is
that no no this is simply our own
treasury management policy
thank you
yeah Max of air funding floating versus
fixed we're sitting slightly out there
that's right there okay
um
yeah thank you
um Patricia just in the area of other
Investments
or cash and cash Investments
um
compared to this time last year that 18
million was about 40 something million
so I guess it seems to me that the funds
that we're traditionally sitting in the
bank have gone across to invercargill
Central
by wave loads
no we
we're Cagle Central the money that would
traditionally been in the bank has gone
into capital projects
so we've spent what that higher level
that we've had in the bank on our own
spending so
look at city streets Tisbury and those
so we haven't specifically gone out and
buried for
okay thank you so so just for that's
just around phasing cash versus date
Rock You
Trisha whether we've started to see a
trend of more rate payers entering into
payment plan Arrangements yes we have
got so we are getting more people
contacting us as they get into
recognize that they have got into
difficulties they contact us we will put
a payment plan in place
many of them hold mortgages so we can
recover by the mortgage
is it as an option but a preference is a
payment plan and that's definitely gone
up considerably in the last year
there's more I wouldn't have said it's a
considerable increase
but there is an a noticeable
more coming through certainly more that
we are collecting on mortgage
than in the past
cycle isn't it okay any further
questions
just a comment you know and I know we've
pushed you a little bit with this
Patricia but thank you for the detail
you've got in that report I think it
gives us a good sense around
you know expenditure and those sorts of
things so I appreciate the effort there
um right so
mover and seconder for the
thanks Darren thanks Barry
um so we're receiving the financial
update and recommend that
um we note that ex sensitive expenditure
for the period one January 23 to 30th of
April so
all those in favor against carried
thank you
right invercargill Central outcomes
report this is by Andrew welcome
uh look I think this is a fairly simple
report but I just think it's really good
practice so in Council considered a lot
of factors when he'd invested in
invercargill central limited and one of
those factors was a report from NZ iar
around the potential broader benefits to
Southland and and invercargill and South
and more broadly from the investment and
that was one of the key factors that
Council took into consideration when
determining whether or not it should
step into what is effectively a
commercial space and so I just think
it's important the council got a report
back to say were those outcomes realized
how did it transpire as to why you
invested and did you get those outcomes
and look it would also be potentially
good practice to do this again in a
number of years but the building is
complete and it's inappropriate that you
receive this report at this time and
consider that and reflect on the reasons
for investing
thank you questions
no way Andrew just a couple of questions
that I guess the public sometimes asks
me
um which is not the detail of the level
of detail you've got in these reports
which is great
um
I guess it's it's two things one the
money we've invested the return
I think you've signaled that before so
that's just a lay a lay term but we
we've always said and and in reports
later on we'll see that it's 10 years
before the equity investment would be
expected to see any sort of return on
that money but that's not to say that
there's not a return to a community sure
I don't refute there yeah and the other
issue is they I constantly asked about
what's the occupancy like
uh in ballpark figures
we still got some space there is some
still some space and I think I mean
again without going to a great level of
detail and I don't think it's
commercially sensitive because it's
quite obvious the the real difficulty we
have at the moment is the first floor
um and uh it's interesting you ask me
that question because it's continually
changing um and I can these changes
literally since we've been sitting in
this room as to occupancy which is
obviously filling up those spaces but uh
the real problem we have is the first
floor
but I think the retail space on the
ground floor I think you can say is now
pretty much 100 yeah and just a last
question on that chair
um
can you give us any update on what's
happening with the what people refer to
as the big space that sits behind the
Bank building which was to be I think a
medical center at one stage uh there's
still ongoing discussions but none of
them are progressing anywhere in a hurry
it's fair to say
um there was two spaces there there was
always what was ideally putting the
original plans as a Piazza sort of
concept over the top and and In fairness
that that piece of work uh really
requires a solution for the pieces of
land around it because that will be used
to tie them together so if the medical
center goes ahead then that will trigger
some further piece of work or or if a
site goes on the piece of land next to
the bank building then that will trigger
different work but at the moment it's a
bit of a chicken and egg scenario which
which comes first
thank you
okay
I just
um one just with respect to the report
um it doesn't say how many people are
employed within that
bycl in terms of all the shops and bits
and pieces currently employed yeah not
just by ICL but you know all the people
that work in retail and they're Precinct
I note that they say they you know they
can't they haven't done the water for
around death we hadn't have done it what
would have happened but in my mind I
think that would be quite material the
difference in terms of social good and
benefit and even employment where
because we've done this there's a number
of business that have stayed and there's
a number of people employed and that's a
real social benefit but the purport just
didn't sort of try and even
so you just to clarify you talking
people employed in the center itself or
are you talking yeah and I I can't give
you that number off the top my head I
have asked for it I know I do know what
it is and it was uh it was in the
original modeling I can get it back to
for the next meeting but it was a
slightly under what we were hoping but
not significantly I think it was about
75 of what the forecast was in the
original modeling yeah um
so but it was good to see also that it's
called out you know the positive
impact that people have had from you
know the emotional
Pride they feel in the city it's
wonderful to see that reported yeah so
that's good
the only other question I had before I
go to Barry was just with your report
you talk about risk
um and I know in our last audit and risk
we talked through you know us not
drilling into risk enough and yet we
haven't called out any specific or a
southern remain a number of financial
risks and I think in these reports we
need to see those risks put there so
that when we go through q and
um
you know whatever quality assurance that
we've actually had it reported through
to these committees what those specific
groups are I think that's too General on
the back of that feedback we got from
audit and risk if there's if this didn't
have some other reports in public
excluded I would have been a bit more
expansive yeah well even if you put
these are covered in other papers that
have been presented to the committee I
think you know we said about that in
order and risk and we need to then
behave
in the way that we've agreed to which
was just identify risk more clearly with
any papers
Barry yeah in relation to the parking
building up top
um is there a reason why they'll heard
it from quite a few of the retailers
that they're a bit annoyed that the time
free time up in the car park has been
reduced by quarter of
a significant amount
um and
to put it bluntly uh the the car park uh
was always built as a revenue for the
development I mean the significant
portion of the cost is in that car park
and so it's to make sure that gives us
the return it means
it's the simple answer
yeah yeah it's a revenue this is
yeah and at the same time the price of a
permanent Parkers went down
yeah can you sleep
thanks Mr chair just to follow up on
Barry's comment
um I just wanted to feed back that the
disabilities community at a recent
consultation on the long-term plan had
commented on that particular issue
because for them it takes extra time
once they have partnered and they are
finding the half air
um
very short so I I did say I would feed
that issue back that it actually creates
a difficulty for disabled parking in the
um
just in response sorry I think there's a
number of issues that came up as part of
that consultation and I fed those back
through the management of the center to
have a look at and consider so I'll come
back and actually know the answer
yeah that's a good that's a
consideration we need to take it isn't
it
just a quick reflection on what Lucy
just said it's all I guess uh I guess
going forward you you'd want to ask the
question
if we uh we required to provide
disability parking or are we provide are
we there to provide longer time for them
to shop or get out and shop
um
and if that if it's the latter then we
should have some designated ears that
are exclusive before that they might
still have an hour on free as opposed to
happening and free
we would have to provide designated
disability parking within the thing and
that's provided isn't it but it's how
you manage the time difference you have
to do that through the pay system and
the set balancing act that will get all
the way through this where there's yeah
and the expectations and councils just
an investor in a commercial Enterprise
yeah um but as I said I've fed them back
and I'll make sure the the consideration
those things does come back to council
because you've got a Julius the investor
to understand that and have some input
into those decisions yeah
that's a good cool
okay so
um
yes can we have a move on second to see
Darren and Leslie thank you so we're
receiving the report from the cocoa
Center outcomes noting the quality of
and quantitative benefits setup
in the NZ I uh report for the CBD
regenerating revisiting 29 estimates and
confirm the community wellbeing outcomes
continue to outweigh the risk of
investment so
Leslie thanks Mr chair look as the
seconder I just think it's worth
um
emphasizing the interesting reading and
the New Zealand Institute report on
exactly those things that we aim for in
taking the decision to invest in this
project
particularly the role of council as a
catalyst and the references in the
report to the fact that without
council's willingness to
um to invest as in a joint venture that
this would not have happened
and I think it's also important at this
point to reflect I think all of us have
had extremely good feedback from the
public on the difference that the
complex and the associated works such as
the street kitscape works and the
involvement of monofinoa in the um
in the design of the these Street spaces
Etc I think we've all had very good
feedback on that I think it's a good
time to acknowledge that in fact
this has been an investment that as it
says where the community well-being
still does very much outweigh the risks
yeah
yeah okay so got to move in a second all
those in favor of the three motions
against carried
okay
um so
late open uh late item
um the approach to naming of air museum
so the paper excuse me which you know I
have to leave your excuses thank you for
your efforts
um right Steve welcome thank you Mr
chair good afternoon councilors
um so this is a an approach paper that
just sits out how we're proposing to
name our new Museum
and I'll take the paper as read I think
the real key importance for us is to
make sure that the name reflects
something that recognizes the importance
of this place to our community and
something that you've heard of a lot
from the community over many years
that it also talks to the nature of its
design and also its prominence as as a
future icon facility for our city so
the approach sets out how Council as the
overall determiner of the name but how
we partner with monofinoa too
um to get a name that reflects I guess
uh the journey that both cultures have
been through and so this paper sets it
out and happy for any questions
thanks Steve questions
uh eviland
so
um
the first thing is that the paper
recommends asking the ueas on committee
as part of this process the evil liaison
committee is the advisor and support to
the Smeg trust board not to the museum
as such not invercargill city council so
I'm not sure why that
was the Avenue that was chosen
um
I would have thought that at the very
least
it would be through the runaker either
through the two that are part of the
invercargill city area which is awarua
and waihopai or through the four but the
other thing that happened is that this
part of this discussion was set out to
the Erie liaison board members and the
first thing I hadn't even had the Reddit
when somebody rang up and said why are
we being asked again
we have already told you the evil
liaison committee two years ago offered
the name
the evil liaison committee
confirmed the name about six months ago
I think you're building up
within my community
a little bit of the interpret about the
process so leaving that aside I do not
think it really hasn't committee is the
correct venue the Avenue for this this
is arunaka issue
um we'll leave aside that the fact that
renaka has already offered a name but we
did not impose a name we were asked to
provide a name we gave a name that had
meaning we gave the story behind the
meaning I am a little bit unsure what
more can be reasonably expected of us
because apart from going to something
that does not speak to us
as part of a story
so therefore just a technical thing
where you pick up a dictionary and you
look at the three words or whatever it
is and you say we'll put those together
and that's what the Maori name will be
which is not the option that most places
choose these days but I do
feel quite strongly that this is getting
to the point of being actually offensive
we are we're asked we provided I don't
actually understand why we are
revisiting this yet again
so just to clarify so that
um
the committee
that
represents
ewe in the in Smeg yeah gave the name
it was two years ago 2021 but but then
you're saying it's not the right place
to now receive the name from uh
uh empowering legislation or no that's
not the right word we have a different
board now that manages the Southern
Museum and art gallery Tonga yeah and
that is what the Erie liaison committee
is attached to it is not attached to the
operational activities of the museum
when it first existed the two things
were combined together so so has the
makeup of that would substantively
change from two years ago
the people on the board have half have
changed yeah
however the board itself Revisited this
approximately six months ago when it was
raised
um shortly perhaps after the election
not quite sure sometime around about
then I would have to actually go back
and look at my minutes but I believe it
sometime around about then and so they
at that time they were still operating
under the same board structure and they
confirmed the name
but they also talked to their
representative Veronica before they did
that so it's really the rename so yeah
so if if the name was given is adopted
the Rooney would be happy with that in
your view
at Stonewall that is what we all agreed
on
um
and whatever else counselor wants to put
with that is not our issue what what
we're saying is that that is the name
that we offered it has a meaning it has
a story behind it and we're not quite
sure by that part of which it's being
Revisited I think so future questions so
Steve and then party and then Tom yeah
look thank you Mr chair one of the
reasons and and I appreciate that the
governance has changed with the
collections trust
um but one of the reasons that we're
proposing this route
um
to seek the feedback on the name is that
uh of all structures that the yearly
liaison committee is is really close to
the service and to the history of this
place but the one thing that
um I guess none of us have seen yet
is the actual design of the facility and
if you recall I think the name
exe is reflective of the design of the
facility and so what we want to do
through this process is to share the
design with the committee to actually
give the committee a chance to to
reflect on
the design and what it's looking like to
go well actually this
is still the appropriate name and that
would be appropriate feedback but it
also gives the committee a chance to go
actually
there's something else and the feeling
of this place now and so that's what we
want to do through this process it's not
to disregard
the feedback but it's to provide a a
current
view to that committee to say does this
name still stand or is there something
else and that's the feedback that
council is seeking
um so I just wanted to clarify the
reason as to why you know approaching it
yeah that's well Sunrise I think Steve
um I just want to share that I
I and it was written it was within my
report this has been raised three times
at this table or questioned in some way
or form
and
um I just want to note that there was a
bit of disappointment around that given
that the name was scripted in good faith
in June 2021 and it was well thought out
and I I think there's just this well why
is it being questioned sorry I just want
to just leave it there but but given
what Steve's explained around we're
further down the path we've got design
we want to share the design absolutely
yeah there's an alternative view that
says that we're actually trying to
partner in a really meaningful way here
because we've got something that
physically you can see now and if you
come back and say
hey this name still fits then that's
that's fantastic but equally I think
it'll be offensive as the word's been
used if we just bold on and then someone
said actually it didn't fit you know we
we're not the expert so we're looking to
seek that out so I think that's the
intent you need to take on with this
paper
what I was going to say is that there
needs to be a mutual agreement on the
names Mutual implies two parties but
there's actually more than two but I
mean I think we I think we need to
arrive at a name that all of us can get
behind and whether that's some other
name then you know it remains to be seen
but it's much better if it's mutually
arrived at mutually agreed and you know
and I think with this paper Seasons but
what do you actually the paper but you
could probably do in a paragraph I mean
what this paper I think says is that we
um you know we need to eat process by
which we can arrive at that yeah and and
I think what's been suggested in terms
of you know who we should be speaking to
in terms of the at EB Partners
um you you know I think Evelyn has said
well that's probably not correct
actually so we need advice on that but
but I mean it's I find it hard to find a
problem in my mind with the idea that we
should have a name that we can all we
can all agree on yeah a mutual meme yeah
and that's the intent yeah
yeah Navi
um yeah I think it's a wider issue than
that's what's been narrowed down so I
guess I've heard about the we don't get
to talk about the Terio interpretation
but it's wider than that because one of
the things that we need to consider is
whether we call it Southern Museum as
the first part or whether we call it
muraku now I'd prefer to have the mariki
person myself and I've been quite public
about that but I can't align with that
name unless I have ewe blessing because
muraheku means more than just Southland
as our territorial area it goes beyond
there those boundaries go beyond yeah
that's right so I want to make sure that
in that discussion yeah which goes back
to you either we're not just saying well
you know what do you want the interior
interpretation to be it's actually are
you okay if we were to name it murihiki
or if you're not then we go back to the
South one which was initially our
starting position so it's both the other
the other thing I think which Tom
referred to anyway it was wheelchair is
the issue of design and when I go back
and look at the Museum that's still
sitting there
um arterio below it talks about a
whale's tooth and because when you sit
back down on Kelvin Street or whatever
it is or further down there on the
street
it looks a little bit like a whale's
tooth and it has some relevance And when
they see the new design I guess I'd like
to know that ewe have some beliefs that
the name that they've already given to
us is still appropriate for the design
of the building because it will be quite
inspirational and if it is that's great
and if it's not then they give us
another thing yeah
okay so I've got trash then Leslie then
Alan
thanks very much I think that the
gush in here has been really useful
I see that
going back to ewe is respecting them
because when it was gifted to us it was
a museum and art gallery and it was a
pyramid it was a different place so what
we're saying is
um now we've got this different look
it's a different we're in a different
spot it's just a museum
is this still exactly what Nobby see
this is still relevant or are there
other names that you would consider so
what I I really believe that
um what's proposed is that we actually
are respecting the ewe by giving them
the opportunity to say yes this still
fits or no okay
thanks
Lucy
thanks Mr chair
um
I just wanted to comment on the fact
that it's my understanding that the ewe
liaison comedy is appointed by the
runaka
and in this case it would seem to me
that it might clear up at least a little
bit of the confusion
if it's clear that we go back to the
source the runaka
rather than the intermediary the ewe
liaison committee which as Evelyn has
pointed out now actually has a different
relationship from what Evelyn and pania
pointed out actually has a different
relationship so it would seem even more
important to go back to the parent
it then becomes a question of whether
it's
the two or the four and Evelyn and pania
may have a definite view on that
um
and indeed some counselors may have a
view that it foreign
or the two but it would seem to me that
that might clear up some of the
confusion if it is the actual roonaka
who asked the question
the ewe liaison committee members would
be no doubt involved as part of the
arunakas in that particular issue and
would certainly feed him that they had
offered the original name Etc but it
just seems to me it would be much
clearer if if it was clear that it's the
runaka we're asking at this point and as
Trish says that's respecting arunaka
um in the seniority of the
the
runaka who have appointed the community
so so in effect what we're saying is
points three and four in the paper on
page 84 a board box we would we'd pull
out and put it on the motion here and
amend that to instead of saying the irre
liaison we would access name the Rooney
yes and then
that would be the consultation process
is that you Steve do you want to comment
on that yeah I'd like to comment on that
um look I think that's a suitable
approach in terms of
whether it's two or four I think the
best approach would be to ask the four
runaka because we have a regional story
to be told and certainly the scope of
our storytelling is a story of Southland
yeah and so I think that that would and
that's the scope of the committee and I
think that as a starter would be the I
guess my recommendation so that's
hokanui in then
um
yes
yes if I'm going to be the proposer of
the amendment
well we've got uh Ellen and then Darren
where are you
Mr we were confused because I thought we
actually already had a name
um it was 10 hour I thought we that was
the name I would so I'm just wondering
why are we revisiting this again
it's just a little bit confusing to me
because we had a name now whether we
call it tanoa Southern Museum or
whatever that that's okay but why are we
revealing something that's sort of
already been done just a little bit
unsure sorry it's deep yeah thank you
through you Mr chair like um I think
that the mayor actually provided an
answer to the counselor's question is
that we actually haven't resolved the
full name
uh we don't know if it's the Southland
Museum the Museum of Southland
motohiki museum museum of motoku
and actually that's the part of the
feedback process we're not just after
the today
interpretation and the confirmation
we're actually after the feedback on the
fall now which includes English and
Maori yeah and so I think that's
for me that's the sort of feedback that
we're looking at but and we also are
doing this
with the support of a hopefully a very
early concept design that we can share
with those people engaged in that so
that they can see and sense the facility
as it is starting to come out from on
the paper
yeah and also I think we've increased
the scope of who we're Consulting
because hoganui and
aparima were not part of the original
well I don't I don't think we are I
think we're following good process
around we have to have a decision made
together with um the you know the
council in in ewe and where we've got a
slightly changed playing field because
we actually have got design we will show
design to them and we want to make sure
that that the naming process aligns with
the design
and um and and they've got the
opportunity to confirm if they want to
stay with the name then so be it when
we're not saying they can't and we're
not saying we don't like it we're just
saying we want to check back and I think
it's a good process
um Darren
I'll be careful here because there's
there's a few degree of
misinterpretation we're all
misunderstanding that's going around in
in many senses largely I'm I'm
comfortable with the process and that
it's a going back to clarify that given
the new design Turner is still an
appropriate name
um
for the today portion of it and that
there's consultation around the use of
South America I see that as as useful
um but the tenua side if that stays I
think we just need to be clear on how
gifting works
um because of I had a birthday last week
or if somebody gave me a shirt I don't
go it's a nice shirt but I don't like it
could I swap it for another one
it's not really a relationship process
like that
um
but if the runaka are comfortable with
10 and there's two being relevant and
are given the chance for some input
around Southland
I guess there's just been a little bit
of misunderstanding around process with
uh runaka and I really Azam comedy so
yeah well it's not certainly not the
former it's the later yeah yeah Mike do
you want to jump in yeah thank you
through your chair um I just want to
step us back in time a little bit
um sorry new councilors but
um
in relation to when we got the naming it
was at the time gifted and Associated to
a working title for the museum and the
reason it was a working
um title was the principle that we
hadn't got the finalization of the
design at that point I think it's only
um respectful that once we get to this
design phase and we're in the position
that we Now understand what the design
is starting to look look like that we do
Circle back to say
um back to the roonoke are you still
comfortable with that working uh to make
that working title actually the correct
name now going forward or do you want to
actually make a change now you've seen
the initial designs I think that's the
stage we're at and that's a cycle
through the process I I think it's been
lost at the time when it was originally
discussed right right way back about
that process in relation to the design
but I'm I'm sure that the roonaka would
not like a
um a name that does not reflect the the
output of the museum so we need to be
courteous and give them that opportunity
I've got Evelyn named Barry and then
Ellen
um so it's to clarify in this in this
particular paper we are not being asked
to feed back on
the issue of Southend or Mexico or
Museum of South and or Museum of
manihako
that's how you would like to amend it
I'm not in the position to move or
second anything because I'm here as a
participant not as a member of this this
committee but then I would suggest that
you add that to the consultation
document because I think otherwise
you're going to be Consulting twice on
something so if you want to provide four
alternative names and say which one do
we prefer and specifically do we wish to
use the word which is
um
pointed out
means up to the waitaki and which is not
within the design brief or the normal
scope of what we would consider to be
the story of South fund so I think you
need to be quite intentional about that
but we I didn't comment on that because
I did not believe that that was what we
were being asked to comment on by this
paper I think if you want to include
those issues then that is quite a good
idea because that means that we we deal
with everything all at once
thank you
Barry yeah it's a major worry to me that
this is going to turn out like mosgiel
swimming pool is with a total merry name
on it I'm quite happy with a a English
name at the bottom top and Mary name at
the bottom but quite frankly that's just
about where I'll stand
okay Ellen did you anyway I was just
going to say that um correct me if I'm
wrong but when um Maori gives a name
like this it's got nothing to do with
the design of anything it's more about
the meaning am I writing that it's got
nothing to do with design so that's why
I'm wondering why do you need to revisit
it because I don't think if it looks
like a whale's tooth or that makes
that's not what the name is all about
am I right I'm gonna say that or am I
wrong to tell you father the story
behind that about a whale's tooth that's
the story of Kiwa and Kiwa
um so
um the tooth that fell out of the
whale's mouth and became
um so under Island
um so if you go back to when that name
was offered the fact that people
persisted of calling it The Pyramid
um actually took away from what the the
gifting of the name was but if you look
at the name that has been proposed for
this in having been privy to some of the
design concept I would say that it still
does fit quite well but I'm not
pre-judging what Renata might say they
need if if the wish is that they see the
design before they confirm the name then
I'm happy to go with that but I do think
that adding the alternative about what
the other names that
you know sort of feedback on the medical
versus self-in conversation very happy
to entertain that as well as for what
happened in mosgiel I think people who
are getting their Nickerson are not up
there need to remember that the name of
the stream that they took away from that
place has actually been replaced on the
landscape by the naming of the poll so
that's their business that's the choice
that they made but
people
when
ronaka asked whether it be here or an
otako or in waitaha whatever
they usually do look back at the
landscape and they do look back at the
stories of the past when they chose
the names that they give and it's not
just looking up in a dictionary
something and saying oh here you go it's
meaningful yeah yeah thank you so you
were right here yeah uh Leslie the
intrusion
thanks Mr chair I'm wondering if
I asked the runaka to also comment on
the use of South London
as the English equivalent name
yeah
what were you originally I think those
are the two words that that we are
talking about in the English I think
that reflects what I was going to say is
that the council and either to play the
council makes a decision and so we would
want the runaka to offer their
suggestions
was for God to murder heku or whatever
else and we would look at those so you
know we've got we've got to respect beam
and as Tom said it's got to be
reciprocal but it comes back to us is
that the council can comfortably levels
of this world
can I come in again
just wanted to reinforce again that I
guess not really ask from my speaker not
really asking ewe for uh their idea on
South and that was a position we talked
to start with when we first started off
this project we talked about the
Southern Museum and having some Trio
naming to sit alongside it
and but sensing what's involved is it is
it more appropriate say America given it
to many Southerners of America is quite
a quite a term or a name that's well and
engaged in our community and where that
would be more reflective of Terraria to
have that as well as something else into
an awful that was quite a positive step
but I am mindful of the boundary issues
and whether that would prefer well with
the four Knuckles the other issue I'd
have is I think Steve touched on this is
um we do have a degree of urgency with
us so yeah uh our plans are coming out
and
um certainly by the sort of the early
part of August we need we need as a as a
council to decide what our name of our
Museum's going to be we're doing a lot
of promotional work around funders and
they need to have some certainty to that
there's a bit of an image involved with
doing that so yeah we're not going to be
mucking around too much of it no just
you know how you get back from foreign
to somebody one of the two um delegates
here take some responsibility for
actually coordinating that I mean do we
have to coordinate it I mean
so that we get it back on time
to say we've got a combiner in
affirmation at the end of July so we
would be able to do that but we would
have to see the design first so of
course the other predicate for that is
that that design will be available for
us to show
um well I have suggested to Lee I think
he's still here
he's done a runner I mean I haven't seen
the design yet but I did say to him it's
really important while they're keeping
that Under Wraps to show that they were
in
early stage even before councils get to
see it so they can have some idea what's
being proposed yeah yeah so that that's
been taken into account in terms of yeah
I've seen
yeah
where do we go Tom sorry
foreign
is probably redundant but I was going to
say that when it seems to me that when
it's a double battled name you know in
other words if it's you know mirahuku
Museum or something like that you know
hyphen turn yeah then the the it's a
real part of the name should absolutely
be the decision though
the um ewe you know I I think you know
you're going to use an English name
under an email then you know then
clearly that that call
where is an individual name it's
assuming me that there needs to be some
mutual thought that the the question of
gifting I know we're going to come back
to this another meeting but the question
of gifting where the implication is that
you haven't been gifted at have to
receive it the problem for me now is
that very often metaphors in one
language don't work any other language
and to be honest I think this building's
an example of that where you've got a
metaphor that works in today that is not
actually work in English and and you
know so therefore I think it does need
to be a mutual discussion but it's a
single name but it's a double barrel
name I think it's different because I
think you know the two halves the
English part you know and the EB part
can be you know keep it in by each party
yeah okay thank you I think we've
covered it so pretty much the
discussions that preceded the paper
being put together really reflected in
the council's comment that's fair is not
Steve so very much a United approach
collaborative making sure we take
account of you know big partners with
ewe we want to have you know both
English and Maori reflected in the name
and
um the Design's a prominent piece of how
we get to that naming process and then
the actual dates line up as well don't
they around July August yeah which fits
in with your concern
just one quick thing
um and you've got up there it's south of
Slash murihiki for me personally I think
it should be Southern or more yeah not
hyphenating the two and then having some
Terio after that it just it makes it
started yeah
yeah why not yeah
right so we've amended the Motions we've
had good discussion and thank you for
all the input
um particularly from their Mana funeral
reps um so a mover and a second or two
thanks Darren thanks Leslie so we're
receiving their report approach to
naming a museum where I prove their
proposed approach
with the following change that in place
of the ewe liaison committee reference
to the four
um
papatypus
and request the runanga to also provide
comment on Southland or mirahuku is the
English equivalent name
so having
reflect on that all those in favor
against
carried well done good work
okay
okay so we'll move Neil to public
excluded so
um moving into that to confirm the
minutes of the public excluded meeting
on the 18th of April in the 9th of May
and the 23rd of May and get us all the
young the live stream has ninja
no no we've just got to disclose it
um the financial update for 2023 the
investment property portfolio update the
business enhancement project dashboard
invercargill Central monitoring report
in the invercargill central limited
funding status report so can I have a
mover and a secondary move thanks Leslie
thanks Darren all those in favor
against carried right live stream turn
off